this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash biographics to
get a two-year plan with a huge discount
plus four additional months for free
more on them in a bit
try and picture the stereotype of a 20th
century latin american dictator what do
you see we're guessing it involves
absurd military uniforms callous
disregard for human life and an ego so
big it could be seen from space now take
all of those qualities and dial them up
inflating each one until it becomes just
a mere caricature a cartoon villain of a
human being well congratulations you're
now about halfway to imagining the
absurd bloodthirsty tyrant who was
raphael trujillo absolute ruler of the
dominican republic from 1930 to 1961
trio was the proto-typical latin
american caudillo vain pompous and
unbelievably sadistic under his watch
the entire population was subject to
arbitrary detention torture and murder
all while blazing neon signs
proliferated beaming his name into the
caribbean knight yet it wasn't just his
vice-like grip on his own nation that
kept trio in power hailed as a reformer
and ally by the u.s trio enjoyed access
to senators and presidents even as his
regime conducted racial massacres and
plotted the assassination of world
leaders today biographics is delving
into the life of one of the bloodiest
dictators in latin american history
[Music]
in the dark days of the truatto there
were certain things that no one in the
dominican republic could say out loud
much of it was standard dictator stuff
criticizing the regime whispering aloud
the tyron's mocking nickname of the goat
but some of it was stranger more
personal for instance there was an
official version of raphael trio's
background one that got taught in
schools one that covered his
aristocratic european ancestors in my
new detail but woe betide anyone who
dared go beyond that to whisper the
truth during the regime there was no
quicker way to get yourself murdered
than by openly discussing the goat's
working-class non-white roots born
raphael leonidas tree home molina the
future dictator first opened his eyes on
the 24th of october 1891 in a village on
the southern coast the third of a
staggering 11 children trio ended a
family that wasn't just blue collar but
actively poor to supplement his income
the boy's dad would rustle cattle rather
than go to school trio was sporadically
educated by willing neighbors but while
his unglamorous origins would cause him
shame in later life they would have
nothing on his ancestry trio's mother
yusu was half black the product of a
union between a dominican and a haitian
and in that place in that era nothing
could be a source of greater humiliation
the only two nations sharing the island
of hispaniola the dominican republic and
haiti have long defined themselves in
opposition to the other founded by a
successful slave rebellion haiti was
defiantly black and caribbean a nation
where french creole was the lingua
franca trio side of the island by
contrast was spanish-speaking and firmly
orientated towards europe ever since a
bitter two-decade occupation by haitian
forces ended in 1844 dominicans had
grown to see their neighbors not just as
different but as alien savages hence the
lifelong horror trio would feel at his
own haitian roots hence his desperate
need as an adult to use makeup to
lighten his skin tone by the time he
finally reached power the goat would be
so obsessed with race that he'd dedicate
himself to ridding the dominican
republic of its non-whites but all of
that was still way in the future for now
young raphael trio would lead the life
of any other kid from his area joining a
local gang making a bit of money through
theft and forgery yet even as he hung
out at the bottom of the social chain
forces were at work that would soon
conspire to take this poor mix-raced boy
to the very very top if haiti was the
dominican republic's hated sibling then
uncle sam was the playground bully who
pantsed them both and stole their lunch
money as early as 1905 washington seized
control of the dominican customs agency
to pay off debts effectively holding its
finances hostage but this was only the
beginning in 1915 woodrow wilson ordered
u.s marines to occupy haiti on the
pretext of maintaining order in the
caribbean at the same time washington
started making noises about also taking
over the dominican republic if it
couldn't stabilize its politics
predictably the threat of u.s invasion
did not stabilize anything the dominican
government collapsed on the 7th of may
1916 u.s forces entered the country it
was the beginning of an eight-year
american occupation one that would
completely overturn the established
order it was also the beginning of
raphael trio's rise to absolute power
[Music]
the thing about embarking on an
occupation is that most people don't
like their country being occupied the
entire time the americans ran the
dominican republic they had to deal with
a guerrilla movement one they simply
didn't have the manpower to overcome so
they began to recruit locals into a new
national police force the guardia
nationale among its members would be
rafael trio in the years since we lost
saw him trio had gotten married ditched
his life of crime and gotten a legit job
working security at a sugar plantation
but this was unglamorous underpaid work
unbecoming of a man as exceptional as
trio thought he was the new police force
then was his ticket out commissioned in
january 1919 trio wasted no time letting
his true colors show you know how you
occasionally meet someone usually in an
office who has a tiny bit of power and
just
wields it like that julius caesar well
that was trio as a police officer before
it even been in the role seven months he
was reprimanded for extorting bribes and
sexually harassing teenage girls but
rather than being like maybe we
shouldn't promote the creepy sex pest
the goat superiors allowed him to keep
rising up the ranks in the heat of noise
of the occupation the americans didn't
care if they were training nice people
he just needed them to be loyal and trio
was a lap dog par excellence for uncle
sam in 1924 he'd be promoted to
lieutenant colonel by then though his
benefactors had enough by 1924 it was
clear that the occupation was the sort
of hypocritical failure the u.s would
soon learn to excel at that july
washington went
screw this then handed power to general
horacio vasquez as the last american
troops ran for the exits vasquez turned
for support to the only power left in
the country the guardian nationale that
was the same guardian nacional raphael
trujillo was slowly taking over it took
six years for the goat to make his plans
six years in which the guardian
astronaut was remade into the dominican
army and trio promoted to its chief
finally in 1930 his moment came that
february president vasquez announced he
would seek reelection something the
constitution was super clear that he
wasn't supposed to do in response the
politician raphael estrella urania
whipped up a rebel force which
marched on the capital to chase him from
power before he marched though arena
asked trio to keep the army neutral in
the upcoming fight and trio agreed but
not because he backed urania no no no
the goat had his own plan for the
upcoming transfer of power the moment
vasquez fled trio sprang into action
with new elections announced for may
trio declared his candidacy bullying
irania into running as his vp that done
he unleashed what would soon become an
all too familiar wave of terror rather
than fight fair trio had his soldiers
kidnap torture and kill anyone against
him journalists died in accidents that
certainly didn't look very accidental
crowds of opposition supporters had
machine guns fired into their midst as
the tsunami of intimidation threatened
to drown their vote as the opposition
withdrew hoping to reveal to the world
what a sham the election was instead
they handed trio the keys to the kingdom
on election day raphael trillo pulled
down 95 of the vote taking the
presidency in a landslide just four
months later a hurricane swept the
republic devastating the capital and
killing some two thousand people it was
exactly the stroke of luck trio needed
under the guise of disaster relief trio
imposed martial law he confiscated
opponents bank accounts brought in press
censorship and ended the right to
peaceful assembly just like that the era
of chaos and occupation in the dominican
republic came to an end in its place
began an era of bloodshed and
unparalleled cruelty now we'll hear more
about that bloodshed in just a second
but first i've got a quick word from
today's video sponsor nordvpn now we've
talked about vpns and their benefits
here before this isn't 1999 too many
people are looking for your internet
history bad actors trying to steal your
data and your personal information
corporations tracking your browser
activity to bombard you with ads and no
one needs any of that that's why nordvpn
is so crucial it's based over in panama
which makes it a great option for both
americans and europeans and look a
common misconception is that vpns are
just for people who are looking to play
defense but they're not just about
protecting yourself you'll be amazed at
the different streaming options you have
when jumping on a server from somewhere
else in the world protect yourself or
just play around buy it for yourself or
consider it as a gift for another
internet user in your life with nordvpn
you've got lots of options plus a 30 day
money back guarantee if it's not for you
there's never been a better time to
enhance your online experience with
nordvpn and that's because right now
nordvpn is running a great deal you guys
can grab a two-year plan at a hugely
discounted cost plus an additional four
months for free so head to nordvpn.com
forward slash biographics and check it
out that's nordvpn forward slash
biographics or just follow the link in
the description box below and now back
to the video
the speed with which the dominican
republic transformed into trio's
personal fiefdom was staggering to
behold in the aftermath of the hurricane
political opponents began to disappear
or die in accidents and suicides before
long anyone who could possibly oppose
the new regime was dead in hiding or
pretending to be a loyalist his
opposition neutralized al-jefe was able
to give his worst instincts free reign
today the dictatorship or the truiato as
it's locally known could be said to have
three main drivers centralization
sycophancy and sadism of these perhaps
the key to its survival was
centralization all his professional life
trio had been an extreme micromanager a
skill that he soon brought to bear on
the entire country almost every pillar
of dominican life was routed through el
jefe's office from education to religion
to entertainment to industry this
allowed trio to force through draconian
reforms that whipped the economy into
shape saw the national debt paid off and
the country quickly modernized roads
unfurled across the landscape schools
and hospitals were built literacy levels
leapt from an abysmal 30 percent to a
staggering 96 it was these concrete
achievements that dazzled his foreign
backers in the united states that led to
moments like democratic senator alan j
ellender declaring i wish there were a
trio in every country of south and
central america but while centralization
had tangible ups it also had plenty of
downs the biggest being that trio kept
all of the ups for himself even as the
economy modernized trio was using state
assets to forcibly buy out foreign
companies create monopolies and hand
them over to family members by his death
it's estimated that something like
three-fifths of the nation's workforce
was under his control and up to 60
percent of its land was in his hands
manufacturing sugar plantations beer
production airlines if it could spin a
profit it soon became part of the goat's
empire in fact it's this insatiable
greed that earned him their nickname in
the first place which brings us on to
the regime's second trait sycophancy the
only people who called trio a goat to
his face were probably cerabides
desperate to experience a fun new kind
of torture most people used his official
title benefactor of the fatherland
rebuilder of the financial independence
of the republic first journalist chief
projector of the dominican working class
and genius of the peace generalissimo dr
trujillo it was an absurd mouthful a
word salad dressed with hypocrisy at the
same time though it revealed an
essential truth living under trio meant
learning to massage his gigantic ego
that meant casting statues in his
likeness across the nation that meant
the government falling over itself to
rename streets parks mountains even the
capital city after him it meant neon
signs blinking on roadsides flashing the
message trio and god into the humid
night air it meant every household being
decorated with a sign reading in this
house trio as chief yet even amid all
this adulation that goat's vanity still
got the better of him as dictator trio
took to wearing elevator shoes to appear
taller than his natural five foot eight
inches in later years he added a corset
to hold in his gut not that anyone dared
laugh as you recall the last pillar of
the triato was sadism and it was
something el hefei excelled at the
tortures meted out by the secret police
were as inventive as they were painful
beatings electroshocks and mutilation
awaited anyone who stepped out of line
there are even long-standing rumors that
several dissidents were fed to sharks
but even this had nothing on what could
happen if you were young and female all
his life rafael trio seems to have had
an unhealthy interest in young teenage
girls as an adult the goat would have
girls kidnapped and brought to one of
his ranchers like casa kayoba and once
there well let's just say trio may have
had more in common with stalin's chief
sadist leventry barrier than we'd like
to imagine
as bad as the horrors trio inflicted on
his people were it was the horrors
visited upon his neighbors that helped
rankings as one of history's great
monsters from a boy who despised his own
mixed background raphael trio had grown
into a man obsessed with racial purity
in his mind the dominican republic was
forever in danger of getting too dark of
losing its european roots and becoming
like its hated neighbor haiti back then
the border between the two nations was
relatively porous haitians crossed for
work or love and many in the region had
a mixed parentage then on october the
2nd 1937 the soldiers came carrying
machetes they fanned out looking for
haitians or dominicans with haitian
blood supposedly they asked those with
dark skin to pronounce the spanish word
for parsley per a yeel knowing the
haitians said it differently and so
began the parsley massacre one of the
biggest acts of peace type bloodletting
the continent had ever seen over a
handful of days somewhere in the region
of 17 000 haitians were hacked to death
with machetes their bodies burned fed to
animals or just thrown in the sea in the
white heat of the killing madness took
hold one lieutenant who heard of the
massacre and wanted to impress trio
promptly marched home and shot his
haitian cook yet despite the genocidal
nature of the killings the goat suffered
almost no consequences sure he had to
relinquish the presidency to a puppet
but he remained the one pulling the
strings sure the u.s forced him to pay
conversation to haiti but it amounted to
a mere 525 000
pittance for every person killed nor did
the regime put a halt to its whitening
policies for observers at the time the
flinging open of the dominican
republic's doors to refugees from the
spanish civil war and jews escaping nazi
persecution was puzzling especially as
trio was cozy with europe's fascists but
it was simply the soft flip side to the
parsley massacre tree wanted to drive
black people out of his nation while
also inviting whites in the despot's
hope was that european refugees would
intermarry with dominicans thereby
purifying his nation's race flagrantly
insane as all this is though you
wouldn't know it from looking at how the
international community reacted in the
post-war era the u.s embraced him fully
trumpeting al-jefe's reforms and
anti-communism he met with president
truman and eisenhower then vice
president richard nixon was photographed
clasping his hand and grinning in europe
catholic governments lined up to
celebrate his economic achievements the
vatican showered him with wards but even
as he was playing the golden boy on the
world stage trio was still up to his
nasty old tricks out in the dominican
countryside peasants were being used as
forced labor on sugar plantations owned
by the regime at the same time the
secret police was extending its reach
assassinating critics across the world
most famously this included phd student
jesus galindez who was writing a book on
trio's dark side in 1956 he was
kidnapped off the streets of new york
and flown to one of trio's private
ranchers where it's said that the goat
forced him to eat his own manuscript
before in turn feeding his body to the
pigs eternal as al jeffy and his
despotic regime may have appeared though
it would soon turn out to be an illusion
beneath the surface of dominican society
volcano was starting to rumble a volcano
of anger pent up from decades of living
beneath a capricious tyrant when it
finally erupted there would be nothing
the benefactor of the fatherland could
do to stop his regime from going up with
it
as the 1950s drew to a close trio was
once again reinventing his nation this
time as a haven for other despots
colombian strongman gustavo arroyos
pania sought refuge there after being
deposed followed by venezuelan tyrant
perez jimenez but it was the dictator
who arrived on january the 1 1959 who
changed everything valencia batista had
ruled cuba with brutality easily equal
to raphael tries yet he'd been
overthrown by a bunch of communist
rebels for everyone in the caribbean the
cuban revolution acted as a wake up call
realizing he might be vulnerable to a
similar ousting ajefe even signed a
mutual assistance pact with his great
enemy haiti yet trio wasn't the only one
obsessed with castro's surprise victory
within a month of batista being
overthrown the dominican liberation
movement had formed that june 1959 they
sent an expeditionary force to overthrow
the goat although trio's forces crushed
them it still took a psychological toll
in the wake of the coup attempt el jefe
began to get dangerously paranoid it
didn't help that the wider world was
finally waking up to his successes with
his term almost over president
eisenhower was pressuring trio to step
down at the same time the organization
of american states oas was following the
lead of venezuela's president romulo
bettencourt in demanding the dominican
republic return to democracy shaken
mistrustful trio responded the only way
he knew how on june the 24th 1960 the
presidential car was driving bettencourt
down one of the main avenues in caracas
when it was hit by the mother of all
explosions 65 kilos of tnt detonators as
it passed shattering the vehicle and
killing two people somehow president
bettercourt survived the next day he
went on tv and told the world who was
behind the attack raphael trio it was
the beginning of the end of the
dictatorship although el jefe tried to
claim the bombing was carried out by
rogue members of the security forces no
one bought it the dominican republic was
isolated internationally it couldn't
have come at a worse time just as the
oas and trio's old u.s back has cut ties
the republic was lurching into an
economic crisis desperate for cash to
prop up his regime trio pivoted to
moscow abandoning his long-held
anti-communist beliefs when that didn't
work he tried to find new scapegoats
home accusing roman catholic priests of
a vast conspiracy against him he even
considered assassinating the pope as he
flailed on the world stage though el
jefe still had absolute power at home
even in this worsening economic crisis
and climate paranoia no one dared move
against him by now trio's rule was so
absolute that he thought he was
invincible that his people were so cowed
he got away with anything he was about
to find out just how wrong that
assumption was minerva mirabal was one
of three dominican sisters who acted as
a professional thorn in the dictator's
side back in 1949 trio had tried to
coerce her into having sex with him
holding her father hostage and
threatening her family but mirabal had
stared him down and in the end the goat
had blinked first ever since the two had
hated each other with a passion of
hatred that only grew as minerva and her
two sisters began plotting against the
regime under the name las mariposas or
the butterflies in the late 1960s trio
finally decided that it had enough that
november the 25th the butterflies were
stopped in the car by the regime's thugs
abducted at gunpoint they were savagely
beaten their bodies then loaded back
into the car and rolled into the sea it
was a typical murder for trejo's goons
the sort of thing that happened on a
near daily basis this time though it
didn't nerve the mirabal sisters were
young beautiful popular on the capital
social scene their horrific violent
deaths touched people in a way that the
deaths of countless others never had in
the shattered broken bodies of the
butterflies it seems those who'd
previously been too scared or too loyal
at last saw their leaders through
colours el jefe didn't know it yet but
from that moment on his days were
numbered
[Music]
on may the 30th 1961 a car full of men
sat idling by the road leading to san
cristobal waiting for their prey it was
late evening a typical lush dominican
night further up the road three more men
lurked in the darkness guns loaded and
ready finally they saw it on route from
the capital the chauffeur driven
chevrolet taking the old ghost to one of
his dalliances with a younger woman as
the car drew closer the men readied
their guns knowing this was their only
chance the chevrolet pulled level and
the night exploded in gunfire the
shootout that ended the triato was the
result of a whole lot of people becoming
a whole lot of pissed off at their
leaders increasing madness the military
was involved the opposition even the cia
helped supply weapons with that sort of
backing how could it possibly go wrong
raphael trio's life ended that night his
bloodied form left sprawled across the
road age 69 he lost power as violently
as he gained it it was a triumphal
moment one still celebrated in the
dominican republic today it was also far
from the end of the nightmare with his
father dead el jefe's son raf has
returned to the country and installed
himself as the new boss over the next
few days nearly all the conspirators and
their extended families were murdered
yet ramfest just didn't have the goat's
touch before the year was out he and his
entire trio family would have fled into
exile taking their plundered loot with
them in their place arose a reformist
government headed by juan bosch one that
briefly looked as if it might steer the
country towards democracy but then the
military toppled him in a coup and when
his supporters took up arms uncle sam
stepped right back in with another
occupation under the americans new
elections were held in 1966 returning
old trio loyalist joachim bellagoo as
president a guy who'd clearly learned
from his old boss bellaguer would spend
the next 12 years rigging elections
murdering opponents and having over 10
000 people tortured voted out in 1978 he
returned for an encore eight years later
only finally stepping down for good in
1996. trio may have been long dead by
then but his influence on belgium was
impossible to miss today the cost of the
triato remains unknown although it's
likely very high one estimate we saw put
the number of political murders from the
period of 1916 to 1978 covering the
first u.s occupation the trio years and
believers first hint as president at
north of 50 000 that's a staggering
figure in such a small country one which
at the moment of trio's death at a
population of just 3.5 million yet the
true toll of el jefe's reign might be
even higher as one of the first modern
tyrants in the americas rafael trio
wrote the playbook that countless others
would follow monsters like augusto
pinochet jorge video and the generals in
brazil would all engage in trio-esque
levels of depravity while simultaneously
casting themselves as fervent
anti-communists to play kate washington
after all they already knew such tactics
worked for all his over violence his
sadism his sexual perversions raphael
trio managed to create a world where
presidents and politicians fell over
themselves to praise him at his height
he'd been a darling of washington a
superstar in europe a devil everyone was
only too eager to pretend was really a
saint he may belong dead but the life of
el jefe is still capable of teaching us
a lesson of showing us what nightmares
can be born when our leaders willingly
turn a blind eye to the actions of a
monster
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]